a member of Congress takes the knee the
Cowboys try to take their knee and stand
up to and the president's popularity
surges is Donald Trump playing for D
football we will discuss the
relationship between national sports and
nationalism in elections around the
world after Germany's shocking election
Sunday with an actual journalist Mary M
lane then Arielle David sent Amanda
Presta Giacomo and His Eminence Beaubois
joined the panel of deplorable z-- to
discuss the cowardly Republicans who
killed Obamacare repeal the New York
Times is creepy communism obsession and
the Paris Hilton climate Accord I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
we have an actual journalist coming on
this show typically we try to stick
strictly to fake news reporters but
we're breaking that rule for once we're
gonna have Mary Lane on she's written
for The Washington Post New York Times
or I'm sorry the Wall Street Journal the
New York Times Associated Press and she
has a really interesting perspective on
how these sports protests and football
protests relate to nationalism and
national elections but first we have got
to run down very quickly all that has
happened in the NFL in just the last 24
hours you know Kim jong-un is about to
fire rockets all over the world but we
need to focus on the important things
like the National Football League
so to begin a sports this just broke
about 20 minutes ago Sports Illustrated
is going to run a cover now that says a
nation divided sports United and it's
going to show all these athletes
photoshopped in to be linking arms
against President Trump because that's
why we read Sports Illustrated that's
why we watch ESPN because we want to
hear liberals RAM rattle on about how
much they hate Donald Trump obviously
they're just moving further in this
left-wing direction it's cost them
subscribers its cost ESPN subscribers it
might destroy bundled cable but
nevertheless they will persist last
night the Dallas Cowboys joined the
kneeling gesture during the national
anthem I got a little bit of flack for
this I wrote a piece at the Daily wire
called it's a grand old flag and in that
people said that I unfairly marred the
Dallas Cowboys here is a clip of what
the Cowboys did last night but they were
very adamant about wanting to separate
that message
from the national anthem
all right Lee said as they take any
collectively booze can be heard from
this sellout crowd in Arizona can be
heard over the sellout team of the
Dallas Cowboys what you you could hear
there is there was massive booing when
they all got down even Jerry Jones the
owner got down on one knee but what they
did was they kneeled down before the
national anthem and then they stood up
for the national anthem this seems to me
a distinction without very much of a
difference they are clearly
participating in the protest that Colin
Kaepernick began which is a protest of
this country an assertion that the
country is fundamentally oppressive
toward non-whites and it is part of that
exact same protest now they wanted to
have their protest and eat it too or
something like that they wanted to have
it both ways I think it was too clever
by half an absolute cynical failure but
Dave Rubin brought up this point
yesterday with all of these teams
kneeling down what are they gonna do are
they gonna stand up in three weeks they
say okay all of the racial problems in
the country are over we can stand up now
of course not
they backed themselves into a political
corner if the Cowboys think that this is
their way of getting out of that
political corner by changing the timing
of the kneeling whatever I think it's
pathetic I think these people are
cowards and too big for their britches
they're paid tens of millions of dollars
a year and they're paid to run around a
field and to entertain us
they have to run their mouths about
politics about which they know
absolutely nothing it's it's totally
ungrateful it's inexcusable I won't be
watching not that I watch a lot of
football to begin with
I'll be watching even less now but if it
can end this nonsense then sure that I
suppose that's fine
Sarah Sanders made a very good point a
point that a number of us have been
making over here which is that the
protest doesn't make any sense she said
yesterday quote I think of this the
debate is really for them about police
brutality than they should probably
protest the officers in the field who
are protecting them instead of the
American flag absolutely right it is a
nonsense to protest the American flag
that the very fact of your being able to
protest that American flag without
prosecution is a defeater for your
protest in the first place it undermines
the premise
of your protest which is that the
country is fundamentally rotten and
oppressive toward whichever demographics
of people so a good point from Sarris
Andres I'm glad we missed Scarah Moochie
we were very upset when the mooch had to
leave but Sarah Sanders is doing a good
job Maxine Waters says that Trump should
be impeached over his tweets I don't
think that requires any commentary gotta
love Maxine Waters and then a
Congressional Black Caucus member has
decided to take the knee here is Sheila
jackson-lee
and you cannot a bridge without law and
regulation and there is no regulation
that says that these young men cannot
stand against the dishonouring of their
mothers by you calling them fire the son
of a B you tell me which of those
children's mothers or a son of a B that
is racism you cannot deny it
you cannot run for it and I kneel in
honor if anybody could quite make out
what the point was that Sheila
jackson-lee had to say please write in
and let me know this is the same woman
who compared the Tea Party to the KKK in
2010 she has nothing of value to add to
this country or to the federal
government and she is funny to watch
though she made this she did make one
small point which is that there's no
rule that says that they can't take a
knee during the national anthem I'm not
sure about that there are regulations in
the league governing what they can dance
to in the end zone
I recommend the lyrics to a song that
would be great for them to dance too
cold it's a grand old flag it's a high
flying flag and forever in peace may she
wave the emblem of the land I love the
home of the free and the brave I'm not
sure that they'll learn that anytime
soon but anyway there is now a
bipartisan effort underway to strip the
NFL of taxpayer funding for stadiums
this bill was co-sponsored by Cory
Booker a Democrat and James Lankford a
Republican in June it is now gaining
steam obviously under very different
circumstances and it's gaining steam on
Capitol Hill probably people like Cory
Booker will pull out of that now that
there is this partisan anteye Trump
racial tinge to it but we'll see what
happens that is all the background now
we have if I can ever get my earpiece to
work properly
with that we have to bring in our
excellent panel of deplorable z' we have
a wonderful one today we have Ariel
Davidson from the Hoover Institution
Amanda Prestage jacquimo from The Daily
wire and His Eminence Paul voix so very
quickly I don't want to harp on the NFL
too much but just going around the horn
here Ariel do you agree with president
Trump's handling of this cultural issue
and is he playing 40 football it's a
tough question it's hard to always
predict what's going on in the mind of
President Trump certainly yeah right I
will say this you know I've had a few
people ask me this now and I'll try to
keep it short and sweet
and I always direct people to this
article that Michaels arm excusing
Matthew Bentley put out Weekly Standard
I think it was earlier this morning and
I thought it was really a wonderful
piece written by a Marine veteran and he
sort of you know he said that we should
try to approach some level of
understanding perhaps with both the
people who are frustrated by those who
are kneeling and for those who are
kneeling my one critique would be that I
don't really know what the kneelers want
what the ultimate objective will be um
after this is done are they going to
continue to kneel for 3-4 weeks um are
they going to kneel indefinitely so my
question would be you know whenever we
see any sort of activism there's usually
a primary objective at the end of that
activism and on the Left that's
perpetual revolution Ariel
I know that in Stacey on the right this
morning did a radio show in st. Louis
and she's a great wonderful political
commentator if you don't listen to her I
recommend it um but she sort of
commented she said you know I'm really
curious what they want at the end of
this protesting is there a final
objective that they're they're working
towards in which case let's talk about
that but I think the lack of sort of
having a clear-cut objective is what's
most troubling to me because you know
and I don't have a problem with protest
that's the American you know that's our
that's our fine art in America we
protest like no one else can protest
because we have wonderful laws that
protect us and allow us to do that so
I'm fine with people protesting I just
want to know you know
they're the what are you protesting if
you're not protesting the flag and you
know why are you kneeling during it and
you know there are two questions here
there's the meta political question
which is am i oh [ __ ] do I think it
should be outlawed of course not and in
that sense I'm fine with it
I like our constitutional protections
but then there's the real political
question is it a good protestor is a bad
protest does it help America doesn't
hurt America is it truthful at false and
I think it's absolute nonsense Amanda is
he playing for D football and should he
be well I think so I think president
Trump is doing this kind of for personal
reasons he's just trying to rally his
base absolutely
Dokka and you know health care is a
disaster tax reform again on the back
burner so that being said this was the
easiest trap in the world I mean this is
clearly I don't typically say it's about
president Trump but this is clearly 40
chess or football I'm not sure I don't
know right this is easiest trap in the
world I mean he's getting his enemies to
kneel during the playing of our National
Anthem I mean this is this is not really
just the base this is rallying most of
America majority of Americans who think
that's disrespectful and disgusting to
basically spit on you know the graves of
those people who fought for your freedom
to do that like you said of course you
can it's is it politically advantageous
does it make any sense
is it disrespectful should you do it so
President Trump this is a big win on his
part and and I don't also I know Russell
mote was mentioning this today people
kind of overlook the cultural war but
it's so important to politics I mean
like everything else is just accounting
Amanda everything that isn't cultural is
just accounting exactly so this was
actually it's it's it's a little you
know it's divisive sure but it's kind of
a war that needs to be fought and
President they walked right into
president Trump's trap so a smart move
by him your eminence mr. blye know that
you think it's 4ths so we have to move
on to more news nominally a Republican
senator Susan Collins has given the
final nail in the coffin for Obamacare
repeal after other nominally Republican
senators John McCain and Rand Paul also
vowed to keep in place the law they
promised for eight years too
heel-toe blah we constantly attack
Collins and McCain for stabbing their
party in the back but we seem to let
Rand Paul off the hook what's up with
that well because Rand Paul he dresses
it up in the mob principals rhetoric and
you know Susan Collins and John McCain
they do it for political reasons they do
it so they can look nice to the
mainstream media and yada yada yada but
Rand Paul he's just doing it because
he's mr. ideologically motivated and I'm
standing formal principles and frankly
it's narcissistic and we should call it
out every bit as much as John McCain and
Susan Collins it's getting ridiculous at
this point I'm sorry go ahead
grow up Rand Paul it is navel-gazing you
know there's this excellent essay which
I frequently recommend rationalism and
politics by Michael Oakshott and in it
he says the rationalist the ideologue
ideologues like Rand Paul they're always
standing for something never really
doing anything but they're standing you
know and then they stand there then the
legs probably get tired because of all
this standing well thanks for your
principles Rand Paul it's gotten us
absolutely nothing good job you've
accomplished nothing go home
ariel collins seems to have voted
against this because her state is poor
and because obamacare expanded medicaid
if that is the case if we can get poor
states hooked on this with the
dependence to the federal government
then is there ever any hope to repeal
entitlements i mean that's sort of isn't
that was Milton Friedman's point right
we've I think we might have brought this
up in the past where there's nothing
more permanent than a temporary
entitlement program so that's sort of
you know that speaks to how hard it is
to rollback something once you give it
away or once you start giving in to
people's demands um you know I think I'm
on board again going back to the Rand
Paul notion I'm on board with that we
you know I I'm happy to be critical of
Rand Paul because even though he's
sticking to his quote/unquote principles
at this point you know it's sort of like
we can take what we can get and this is
this would be this would have been a
step in the right direction in terms of
Susan Collins I think we just have a
bunch of people in the GOP who are what
I call spineless jellyfish
you know they run on a certain platform
and they're unwilling to pull the
trigger when it comes to actually
enacting what they've run on um you know
I was one of the people that sort of
caught it called Susan Collins office
multiple times during various votes and
so I you know I have no shame in doing
so I think that um you know it's been
she's been sort of an embarrassment for
the GOP she's not a reliable vote when
it comes to conservative principles and
you know same thing with McCain as well
I think I started categorize them as GOP
sellouts does that mean I think they're
bad people no but I think when it comes
to you know just that's one thing that
bothers me especially on Twitter people
say oh you know you can't criticize
these politicians because you know they
really are good people I'm like yeah
that's fine but I'm criticizing their
policies yeah I don't care if they're
good people and they must be nice for
Rand Paul it must be nice to be able to
stand on the sidelines and pretend at
moral superiority well real men go out
and do the things that you're too afraid
to do and actually risk their political
careers to accomplish the thing that
they've been promising for eight years
must be real nice for Rand Paul what a
what a principled guy love your
principles Rand Paul Amanda is it worth
primaries rhinos and running them all
out of Congress or is a liberal
Republican better than no Republican at
all liberal Republicans have gotten us
nowhere so if we can primary them and we
can kind of use if President Trump can
maintain his base you know and he can
kind of he can kind of push for these
for these these people to be primary
these liberal Republicans then you know
I would say go for it because because as
we saw during the election President
Trump spent you know no money and he's
still wanting just use social media so
that that populist base there is
something to it and all people don't
like to admit that but there is
something to that so if we get you know
if you can get president Trump behind it
you can get this populist base who voted
for Trump for his principles not just
necessarily for the man maybe we could
see some change in that regard
it's always hard to challenge an
incumbent but it's it's possible I voted
for the calf FA I didn't vote for
principles or the man but it's a it's a
minor point okay listen I know that you
all want to keep hearing about the New
York Times is crazy communist obsession
the new Paris Hilton climate Accord and
my final thought on president Trump's
role in all of this but guys you've got
to go to the Daily wire calm and
subscribe thank you to all of the
current subscribers who allow us to keep
the lights on in here but if we get more
subscribers I'll get an earpiece that
works and we'll be able to make the
Skype the Skype function too so if you
go over there right now you'll get me
you'll get the Andrew Clavin show you'll
get the Ben Shapiro show I know you're
yawning while I say this but wake up
buddy you get the leftist here's tumblr
now I've got your attention the perfect
vessel for delicious leftist ears you
can serve them hot or cold always salty
and delicious we've actually had to
order several thousand more for all of
the NFL players we've had we're
packaging up new vintages we'll be
shipping cases very soon so go over to
the daily wire comm right now and we'll
be right back
the New York Times is continuing its
creepy obsession with communism the
former newspaper of record tweeted
yesterday quote for all its flaws the
Communist revolution taught Chinese
women to dream big as our pal ben
shapiro recalls today in The Daily wire
other New York Times headlines in just
the past few months include quote when
communism inspired Americans quote when
the Harlem Renaissance when communists
quote socialism's future maybe it's
passed and finally quote why women had
better sex under socialism and it's not
a joke that's an actual New York Times
headline Amanda two questions do women
have better sex under socialism and has
the Communist revolution taught you to
dream big yeah well I mean you know once
you're out of the bread line and once
you the fend off starvation I heard the
sex is fantastic you know once you have
so many abortions forced abortions by
the government you'll be coming you know
steroid be infertile and then you can
just have as much sex as you want and a
utopia you're painting area socialism is
an old failed dead philosophy why is it
being trotted out as fresh and fun 134
years after the death of Karl Marx right
so I say this is I focused on Soviet
politics in college that was like my
main forte I will say this that I think
the left is having some they need to
engage in some sort of apology because
one of the main attack lines of the
conservative movement is that hey you
know what the left end of the spectrum
they're the ones that are responsible
for communism absolutely in factually
true however now the left in order to
undermine this talking point has to
paint communism with some sort of rosy
lens right even okay so they've accepted
that somehow they're associated with
communism now because you have Bernie
Sanders quasi communist who ran for
public office
so they've accepted that that communism
is part of you no one is sort of the one
branch of their party but now they need
to engage in
sort of apology tour or at least
whitewash it in some way in order to
make it an easier pill to swallow I
think this plan is going to backfire
tremendously because there are millions
and millions of people who have died
under communist regimes that are sort of
they're seeming there's no better
argument against communism than its
existence so with that being said I
think this is sort of the last attempt
to try to whitewash a part of their
history that they don't want to own but
the fact is they own it they have to own
it
and communism will continue to be the
biggest argument against any sort of
leftist utopia and the left has been
doing this forever the New York Times's
Walter Durante famously said we've seen
the future and it works about the Soviet
Union he denied that there were famines
there I mean he was an absolute shill
and propagandist for them but mister
Bois your eminence Paul Bois Andrew
Klavan says that the New York Times is a
former newspaper he says that because it
was a revered institution and now the
left has hollowed it out and destroyed
it made it a zombie now we've seen the
left do this and a lot of other great
institutions they've done it to my dear
old Yale they've done it to corporate
America they've done it to the mainline
Protestant churches it is also said that
nostalgia is history after a few drinks
where these institutions ever really
great or are we just being sentimental
and nostalgic well I mean yes I mean I
mean you went through a lot of
institutions there you went through
corporate America mainline Protestantism
when it comes to the news media I mean
not so much I think if you really look
at the history of it like you just said
you spoke about Walter Durante also in
the 1950s there was operation
Mockingbird that was uncovered in the
1970 that showed dozens of hundreds of
journalists across the country worried
and also in bed with the CIA and we also
have that famous moment during the
Vietnam War when Walter Cronkite after
the Tet Offensive said the war is
unwinnable even though we were winning
hand over fist
you had boxes Ezra Klein creating an
entire listserv called journalist to
help Barack Obama and hurt John McCain
I'm sorry can you repeat that again
we've got yes we had boxes as
line created an entire listserv called
journalist to hurt John McCain and to
help Barack Obama oh yeah there was of
course that I mean so we it's uh it's
been prevalent for four decades now fair
enough we need to move on to much more
important issues global issues like the
brand new Paris climate Accord the Paris
Hilton climate Accord
she has solved the so-called climate
crisis she tweeted out yesterday quote
this is earth it's hot don't pollute as
M police annatee pointed out Paris has
now accomplished more in three sentences
than Al Gore has done in the last 20
years
Arial is Paris a summary of the issue
really more frivolous than that of most
other global warming activists or is it
just more honest is it more honestly
frivolous I think maybe it's more
honestly frivolous because she's not
citing a potentially shaky study so in
that sense she's actually credit her
argument a bit because she's not citing
something that hasn't been at least you
know that hasn't been perfect in its
truth when it has very shaky evidence so
I commend her on that front uh you know
I think there it's funny to me that we
have sort of celebrities entering the
ring is you know quasi experts you have
Jimmy Kimmel who on health care and now
you have parents Hilton on climate you
know I'm really curious to see what
celebrity is going to step up to the
plate and become sort of the
quote-unquote voice of reason I think
this is a we're trending towards a
somewhat dangerous time in terms of who
we look to for advice I think what's
most alarming even going back to the
Jimmy Kimmel thing was that he had been
fed talking points by Chuck Schumer so
I'm curious to see who's gonna start
feeding Paris Hilton talking points in
order to spread her message far and wide
uh but it is very simplistic and it's
not too pushy so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna rag on her too much right I can
get behind not polluting you know I
don't want to subscribe it all over the
street I can do that I guess then left
makes me so reactionary I just want to
like pour vats of oil and little baby
seals and stuff they do this to me why
do they make me do this
Amanda something tells me that Paris
does not lose much sleep over the
climate now I'm curious for what
percentage of climate alarmists are
that are they genuinely concerned and
worried about global warming and for
what percentage of them is this just a
social signaling mechanism I think
there's a healthy majority who see this
as a money-making scam I think and you
know for prominence if you look at Al
Gore I mean he has the beachfront home
why aren't the sea levels gonna eat
everything up I mean it's yeah but I
also would not put what's-her-name Paris
Hilton in this category because I
actually actually admire Paris Hilton I
mean she has done I've never seen to get
so much money and fame so I'm actually I
admire your on the Michael and Lowell
show Amanda true I do take personal
inspiration from her but she's amazing I
mean she she's pretty she got famous for
being famous she got rich for being rich
god bless her that's the American dream
she voted Trump and she voted for Trump
mister voix your eminence in many ways
Paris a summary is more reasonable than
Al Gore's many climate activists seem to
worship the earth to refute the man as
the measure of all things is Paris
Hilton the voice of reason
I mean hey she just says don't pollute
okay all right won't pollute I mean in a
sense I mean Paris really boils it all
down to their essence just like it's hot
don't pollute okay all right all right I
guess I'll try I'll use the blue bin or
whatever fair enough
panel what a reasonable discussion we've
had today thank you for being here a
rare reasonable discussion Arielle
Davidson from the Hoover Institution
Amanda presto giacomo from The Daily
wire and His Eminence Paul Bois now that
brings me to my smart glasses and the
final thought
the president's critics on the left and
right are lambasted him for wading into
the NFL's disrespect for the
star-spangled banner
they say the protest isn't a big deal
that it's not worth the president's
attention as a rule nobody has ever
honestly insisted that quote it isn't a
big deal whenever they say that you can
bet it's a big deal the flag is a symbol
of the country and it is perfectly
within the scope of the president's
rhetorical responsibilities to stand up
against those who attack the country
itself but his critics insist
it isn't seemly for a president to wade
into these cultural issues the country
they say has never been wealthier never
more economically prosperous but that's
precisely the point the country's
troubles at this moment are not
primarily economic their cultural
America did not elect Donald Trump
because he offered the most free-market
tax policies he didn't we did not elect
Donald Trump because he promised to
finally address entitlement reform and
write the country's fiscal ship he
explicitly did not promise that we
elected Donald Trump because he is a
singular cultural figure who echoed not
just the words of Ronald Reagan but the
wish of Patriots horrified to see Barack
Obama apologize for the greatest freest
most charitable nation in the history of
the world who hoped to make America
great again the culture is rightly at
the fore of most Americans minds and we
elected a culture warrior to beat back
the destructive anti-american barbarians
to restore a culture of gratitude for
the country that has given us and the
rest of the world so much and asked so
little in return now more than ever
despite the constant negative press
coffe FA I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show come back
tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]